you might remember that earlier this
year myself and fellow tech junkie Peter
Brown built a PC for a mere five hundred
and fifty bucks now that was great and
all but you know what's even better
spending all the money yes that's right
folks forget meager budgets this video
is all about cramming all thousand
dollars worth of high-end tech into a
case and then basking in the warm glow
of excessive compute power yes ladies
and gentlemen welcome to GameSpot's
Intel x99 mega build when you're
presented with what is essentially an
unlimited budget component choices are
to a certain extent as much down to
personal preference as how powerful they
are that said when it comes to the
ultimate in computing power nothing can
touch Intel's brand-new x99 platform and
haswell-e processors they don't come
cheap though starting at 400 bucks for
the six core i7 with 28 PCI Express
Lanes
and rising to an eye-watering thousand
dollars for this the 8 core i7 5 9 6 0x
with a mammoth 40 PCI Express Lanes
why would you want 40 PCI Express Lanes
while for those doing triple quad or
four-way SLI you can run more cards at
higher 16 or 8 X speeds as for the CPU
itself wow this thing is a beast we're
talking eight cores for 16 threads of
processing power coupled with 20 Meg's
cache support from all new ddr4 Ram
making the only CPU to do so and the
base clock of 3 gigahertz you might have
noticed though that that clock speed is
slower than the cheaper haswell-e chips
and slower than the far cheaper devil's
canyon high-five and i7s to be blunt
this cpu is completely overkill for
gaming most games don't even tap all
cause let alone eight and seem much more
benefit and faster clock speeds but this
is the bleeding edge of tech and if you
want the very best or into 3d rendering
and video encoding this is the CPU to
get to go along with haswell-e is a new
chipset and RAM
and you'll need to fork out a pretty
penny for both I'm using 16 gigabytes of
course as brand new quad channel
vengeance lpx PDR for ramp that's
clocked at 2800 megahertz and cost three
hundred and eighty four dollars a
substantial markup from ddr3 but the
board I've gone with EVGA is none more
black x99 micro at $250 as the name
suggests it's a micro ATX board and
claim a sucker for small powerful pcs
there aren't many mini ITX x99 boards
choose from and to be honest all the
others looked ugly as sin there are
trade offs with the EVGA board though
less PCIe slots Ram slots SATA ports and
are so tiny it's useless
MTS SD slot you can still build a full
and extremely powerful system speaking
of which what's better than one gtx 980
video card oh yes two gtx 980m video
cards coming into over $1000 but why
stop there
how about not one but two of crucial zem
five 5512 gigabyte SSDs 260 bucks each
which we're going to hook up in grade
zero the crazy brief write speeds we've
also got a corsair HX 750 IES u8h 100
eyes cpu cooler sleeve white PSU cables
corsair SP 120 white LED fans and
housing it all as this frankly epic air
2 falls case after a string of small
case disasters and massively impressed
with the space on offer inside the air
240 not to mention it looks freaking
awesome as well
the total cost three thousand seven
hundred and eighty six dollars and
seventy seven cents but what the hell
let's check in some kick out of gaming
accessory to we've got Corsairs
rainbow-colored k70 RGB keyboard a
SteelSeries cents i wireless laser mouse
and a SteelSeries h wireless headset to
cap it all off the grand grand total or
thousand three hundred and eighty one
dollars and seventy six cents a mere
drop in the ocean for bankers property
tycoons and spoiled rich kids growing
fat and lazy off their parents Millions
but just what can you do with a PC like
this well let's put it together
and find out
so here she is folks one of the smallest
most powerful pcs money can buy
naturally with such powerful specs 1080p
gaming at the highest settings isn't
much for challenge and even running
games at 1440p resolution rarely taxed
in to really see what this system could
do we used invidious dynamic super
resolution technology which runs games
at 4k 3/8 40 by 21 16 resolution and
then down samples of them back to 1080p
the performance hit is similar to
running games at native 4k but you get
the same benefits including little need
for anti-aliasing thanks to the
increased resolution for testing
purposes the base strap was bumped to
125 megahertz to get the ramp up to two
thousand seven hundred and fifty
megahertz while the multiplier was bug
to 35 giving us a final clock speed of
four point three seven gigahertz this
gave us a nice balance between speed
power consumption and heat under full
load the system called 560 watts with
the CPU hitting 68 degrees haswell-e
and GTX 980 s are a postive combo as
evidenced by the more than playable
frame rates at 4k in every game we
tested plot all managed to hit a solid
60 frames per second but with a little
tweaking such frame rates are well
within reach the only games not to
approach 60 frames per second were tomb
raider which hit only around 46 frames
per second a problem largely fixed by
disabling tress effects and the ever
problematic Crysis 3 because Crysis 3
it's also worth noting that both
Assassin's Creed Black Flag and
watchdogs suffered from micro stuttering
and it got pretty bad in watchdogs
turning down the texture settings too
high certainly helped but I couldn't
quite get it as smooth as I liked in
time for recording bad show rubra soft
as for more general computer use this
thing's screams in black magic speed
test
I saw peak right speeds of 900 megabytes
per second with peak read speeds over a
thousand megabytes per second and in
Cinebench is multi-threaded test we saw
an impressive CPU score of 1726
beating out stocks eons and Devil's
Canyon i7s so yes this is a killer PC
when it comes to certain finely
multi-threaded tasks but the real kicker
here is the Intel's x99 platform and
haswell-e CPUs which poor old AMD even
further down the performance pipeline
and the company isn't catching up
anytime soon sure this system is
overkill for the vast majority of people
and even those who have the need for 16
overclocked threads on the desktop they
find it hard to justify $1,000 of CPU
but being sensible isn't what haswell-e
is about and neither is this PC right
here you might not ever tap into all its
power and you certainly wrote max out
while playing games it anything less
than 4k no haswell-e
and NVIDIA GTX 980 s I like many of the
finer things in life
expensive exclusive and oh so lust
worthy its tech will eventually trickle
down into cheaper products but for now
if you want the absolute best in
computing Intel's Haswell II is it